it took so long i was nearly crying
equally intense and hilarious storylines
proved to be real obstacles for the cast
of sex education when filming the third
season
it never goes in the direction i expect
it to one actor used specially curated
playlists while another got their ped
dog job on set
whatever they did it worked however
filming didn't come without a struggle
some scenes nearly didn't get filmed due
to travel restrictions and one actor
regularly faced a four hour commute to
set
it's a bit weird
shooti gatwa had a special trick up his
sleeve that helped him get into
character for the third season
especially curated playlist for every
one of his scenes in the season the
actor chose a song to go with it and he
would listen to it when filming not only
that but he chose an astrology sign as
well
in my head eric is a leo and so i read a
little bit about leo and i like apply it
to his lines the song he chose as a
closer for the journey of eric was don't
judge me by fka twigs pretty much the
perfect song for such a fun and
inspiring character the clubbing scenes
throughout the third season are some of
the most memorable and exciting moments
the energy was definitely high on set
and the performers were ready to hit
their marks but getting the enthusiasm
and energy just right for the whole
scene was tricky since only 10 seconds
of filming actually had music playing
for filming purposes the majority of the
dancing was done in total silence one of
the best parts of the hit show is how
much freedom the cast is given so their
improvisation skills can just add to the
comedy i've certainly never done a scene
without improvisation
director ben taylor was often feeding
the cast little ideas with ways to boost
the comedy in the script even more who's
this
steve no i meet the goat this hilarious
moment of amy believing maeve doesn't
know who steve is was brought up by
taylor right before and with that idea
in mind amy lou woods brought comedy
gold for tonya reynolds filming lily's
storyline for season three hit pretty
close to home and proved to be a
struggle for the actress on set i guess
i've learned how different i am from her
but also the things that we have in
common she really related to how
self-conscious lily had become which
could be very overwhelming when it came
to filming leaving the actress unable to
look her cast mates in the eye without
getting too overwhelmed at times
not every scene gets a perfect take the
first time around but one scene in
particular took a record amount of time
to get just right one very awkward and
hilarious scene on the trip to the
battlefields of france ended up taking a
whole lot of takes to get footage that
was usable because the whole cast
corpsed throughout the takes unable to
control themselves
the team almost got into trouble as they
needed to finish filming before dark and
they nearly ran out of time
luckily they managed to hit their marks
and successfully produce one of director
ben taylor's favorite scenes in season
three of sex education asa butterfield
surprised us all with his new facial
hair
since there is a time jump between the
second and third season the actor had to
be aged a little as otis but butterfield
didn't have to worry about growing the
facial hair himself he's very proud of
his moustache what we see on screen is a
fake mustache which the usually
babyfaced butterfield totally rocks
although he isn't the biggest fan
explaining he didn't think anyone could
stand seeing it for too long the dog who
plays ruby's pup in the show is actually
mimi keens in real life and its name is
baby
keen has three furry friends all of whom
accompany her to set but baby is the
star of her family with her role in sex
education i've been working on that for
three years now the actress had been
speaking with director ben taylor since
the first season explaining just how
simple it would be since the dog was
always on set anyway while filming for
the third season was meant to start in
april 2020 the pandemic put a major
delay on production after five months of
waiting the team got back to it in
september 2020 with loads of safety
protocols in place to protect the actors
and crew members
these varied from being tested three
times a week masks sanitizer
aside from the extra time it took to
make sure everything was done safely the
cast and crew didn't have a wildly
different experience filming if anything
there was just more excitement because
they finally had the chance to be in a
room together again considering the
show's daring content and wild
storylines the vibes filming certain
intense scenes could be kind of
confusing leaving everyone crying one
minute and laughing the next you know
there are some emotional bits in a
particularly emotional scene between the
untouchables that didn't end up making
the final cut ruby's friends gather at
her house to support her and mimi keen
was instructed to physically look like
she was crying a bit harder her back was
what the camera saw so they wanted to
make sure the moving moment was still
clear however the actress went a bit too
far and quite literally started jumping
up and down wildly
once the actress was shown how absurd it
all looked the whole crew had a solid
laugh even after all that work great
moments still won't make the season
asa butterfield is just as sweet in real
life as he is in sex education
while the team behind the show was used
to spending loads of time together that
didn't stop butterfield from showing his
enthusiasm and love for the whole crew
every single day
the actor would literally make sure to
say hello and goodbye to each person
individually
part of the reason for this was because
of just how grateful the actor was to
get back to work on set again
a privilege he'd never take for granted
again after being without it for so long
mimi keen has the company of her three
dogs when she heads to set each day and
thank goodness since it can be up to a
whopping four hours to commute each way
while it might seem like a rough start
and end to each day it's actually one of
the actresses favorite parts of doing
the show the drive could be just over a
couple of hours but keen is a huge fan
of the activity and doesn't tire of it
at all most of the cast and crew take
the train but the ruby actress uses the
drive as an opportunity to explore and
see all the wildlife along the way
at least i had the dogs so i was lucky
the actors who play the untouchables
together absolutely adored their
clothing of the series and especially
the way they all looked together one day
in particular saw the actors in an array
of extremely bright clothing that they
knew they had to capture the look of
little moments like these behind the
scenes are a testament to just how close
the cast has become throughout the
series
between takes they're often hanging out
goofing around chilling in their
trailers or taking countless photos of
the fur babies
george robertson is talented there's no
doubt about it but his drawing skills
weren't quite up to par with his
character isaacs the actor isn't
responsible for the drawings but since
doing it for the show robertson began
doing art more himself in his spare time
to practice he may not be great at it
but it's a special gift that he's gotten
from playing the role of isaac tonya
reynolds not only brought lily to the
screen she also captured behind the
scenes snaps on film the actress was
always capturing moments using a real
film camera to share with many many fans
it's just been a real
privilege to be a part of it to be a
part of a team that is so strong
yet another reason we love this cast and
series
the storyline that saw eric going to
nigeria for the family wedding was one
of the most powerful in the whole season
however there was a chance we were going
to miss it all with the travel
restrictions the team struggled to
figure out how and where to shoot the
scenes but eventually they made tv magic
happen and brought the empowering and
celebratory scenes to life the cast and
crew of sex education never fails to
impress while there was a whole lot to
overcome be it intensely emotional
scenes or covet protocol restricting
filming locations the teams still
managed to nail it which scene do you
think would have been most difficult to
film